[Music]
2020
with and without otto beckham jr in
cleveland
five games with 11 games without
you can see the increase in the passing
yardage per game for baker mayfield and
he
generally personally reached the higher
level as the season unfolded and you
could argue he would have done that
anyway regardless beckham will be back
this year here's offensive coordinator
alex van pelt
on beckham's return and what it means
for the offense
anytime you have a great x you see a lot
of coverage roll to
to that player you know that kind of
went away when odell
was injured you know that that opens it
up for
for other players to be successful it's
not always great to be
double teamed all the time but sometimes
that's going to happen when you're great
so
i would expect teams to to i don't have
to honor odell
and potentially at times put two guys on
and i'm guessing that you'd think
that that concept of baker being better
without odell
is not true i think baker was better
as the season went on whether it been no
dell or not had been
still out there he started to understand
the offense more understand what we were
asking him got his footwork right
um and i think he just he he got better
regardless of who was on the field
um as i said earlier you're always
better with great players
anytime you take a great player off the
field you've got to find ways to
you know to generate more offense so
we'll be better with odell moved out
you know maybe they will maybe they
won't it's just been odd to me over the
past couple of years chris the browns
players the coaches and the media
covering the team refused to acknowledge
the very simple fact
that when you bring a guy like beckham
into the lineup
a guy who is not bashful about saying i
want the football
and i remember in 2019 the narrative
constantly was are we getting the ball
enough to obj that puts pressure and
stress on the quarterback
who should be just going through his
reads open
not open that's the question open throw
it not open move to number two
number two open not open not open move
to number three
and so on but when you've got a guy
who's got a very strong personality and
he's got that history of being kind of
the center of attention
and very emotional and he believes
in his mind the more i get the ball the
more likely we are to win the less i get
the ball the less likely we are to win
i just think that that's an untenable
situation for the quarterback
who ends up maybe staring him down
longer than he should
maybe throwing it to him when he's not
covered or if you take the guy away
early
you short circuit the entire game plan
because
then you've got that extra stress we're
not getting the ball to odell yeah well
listen i don't think they're going to
play that way
i mean as far as like hey i expect it to
look a lot like your minnesota vikings
right
it's run the ball it's justin jefferson
it's stealing
you know their guys are going to be
interchangeable in the routes we don't
know if theon's going deep or across the
field we don't know if jefferson's going
deep or across the field
they do the same things i think that
could be the beauty of the offense all
together
and like hey i hear you like you know
at base level you know it the optics
all point to like man something's not
right
there with the situation but i think
like if we look at the broader context
then listen there is reason to be
concerned i hear what you're saying
but like okay year one you know odell
with the browns hey the the browns were
a total they they were all over the
place
you know we we've talked about that they
were dysfunctional
baker wasn't as good the offense wasn't
as good the defense was bad freddie
kitchens was learning on the fly
all those things so i do think baker
felt the pressure a little bit in year
one
and year two i don't know if he
necessarily felt the pressure i don't
think it was but it was like hey wait
we're learning a new offense we got to
get things figured out and do things
that way
we saw moments of special from o'dell
last year
we did i mean listen they don't win the
dallas cowboy game if it isn't for odell
beckham jr
with reverse touchdown catches and a
reverse down the sideline late in the
game when the cowboys were coming back
for a 55-yard touchdown pass
he led the team in receiving with
washington in week three
i mean he had plenty of moments last
year where you went oh i think it's
coming together
but i think alex van pelt said it the
right way like
the offense hadn't come together yet so
yeah the stats improved but it looks
like it's odell but i
i i'm not gonna pin it to that i'm not
and
and uh i know it's something to watch
for but like if they can get
him going the way that offense was going
and really put him together i mean watch
out
they could be scarier than your vikings
offense and what they can do in
explosivity and everything like that
as long as you can get odell beckham jr
to buy that's it
right and if you're if you're winning
and and he's had his fascination with
the patriots for years
well in new england you you start
spouting off you're not getting the ball
enough you're on the bench you're
forgotten you're gone
that's not part of it all that matters
is winning and if the browns are indeed
winning
maybe that's where beckham understands
it doesn't matter if i get the ball or
not and maybe
now that he's seen the offense work
pretty well without it yes
right humbled a little bit let me let me
let me take you back to this quote
though
this is from baker mayfield in november
of 2019
i think people have this perfect thing
where it was going to be sunshine and
rainbows and odell was going to have a
whole lot of one-on-ones
it is odell beckham we're going to have
double coverage
and we have to find ways to format
things
to get him the ball and force feed him
early
where we can make an impact before we
have the perfect look to have a shot
play see that's
that's all wrong you don't have to force
feed it to him
why do you have to force feed it to them
now you can design plays if you said
time and again there are ways you can
design plays to get the ball in the
hands of your playmakers
without the guy having to run down the
field and get open on a pass route right
you can do screens you can do reverses
and they did some of that last year that
was part of the impact he had against
the cowboys that was a great game that
was his best game in cleveland
but that's one thing get him the ball
but don't force it to him
if they know you're going to throw it to
him they are going to try to take him
away and it is going to short-circuit
your entire
game plan so i i just i i think it's
there's so many great receivers out
there where they're just part of the
team
and the ball comes their way when it
comes their way and if it does great if
it doesn't great and you never hear a
discussion point about
it the fact that it's been a discussion
point for the browns in and of itself
tells me
that that there has been dysfunction now
will it
linger into 2021 we'll see
but otto beckham jr just needs to be a
piece of the machine
he cannot be the centerpiece of the
offense he cannot be the guy they have
to force feed the ball to
and if it's anything other than that
it's potentially not going to work chris
that that's that's
what happened in 2019 and they need to
get away from that
in 2021 and i think they were in the
process of last year
i think that's the big thing right like
you know i think you're you're laying it
out the right way
i think 100 you know added to the fact
that i'll add is
you know obj i would think has been
humbled a little bit the last few years
to where he might be even more willing
to be
you know accepting of what you're
talking about like hey just want to be a
piece of the puzzle want to be a part of
a winning team and do my part and do
things like that
you know you know part of the pressure
was yeah it's obj we expect star
play stats highlights everything why is
that happening in cleveland
baker mayfield's a flamethrower why
isn't it happening in cleveland
well you know the first thing other
thing too is like you know
that quote you read right that was from
2019. am i correct there did i hear you
say that right yes
november i would think i would think you
know
again you're not going to hear baker
mayfield or anything like that come out
of cleveland that's the old coaching
staff's
point of view that's not what this staff
is about
they're going to take what's there to be
had to like what your point is
you know yeah they're going to have
plays for odell beckham jr where
he's the first read in a play-action
pass drop back hey odell's the first
read we're kind of designing it for him
to get the ball
but it's not like he's the only guy and
we're gonna just like
oh it's only him and that's it and don't
look for anybody else anything like that
of course they're going to do that to a
degree but they're not going to go out
of there here's the problem
here's the problem yeah here's the
problem right if he's the first read
on that play yeah and baker mayfield
decides he's not
open and goes to number two yeah and
beckham thinks he was open
sure what does beckham do about it then
well becca come back to the huddle and
say i was open or did you just say
nothing i
i think we have plenty of evidence
already to say i already know he'll do
nothing
you know i mean baker didn't play good
in 2019 he missed him a ton
you know we can go back to last year and
i can even show you some
like the pittsburgh game remember when
the browns got blown out in pittsburgh
kind of early on in the year i think it
was the week before odell got hurt in
cincinnati
hey we can all go back and watch some
plays in that game and go
whoa odell's open a bunch either he
didn't throw it to him or he missed him
wide open
odell has handled it like a professional
he has i know we're all
we know it's not like like perfect and
we see that he gets frustrated at times
but he said and done the right things
for the most part and i do think we got
to give him a little credit for that
he has not gone diva mode or like we saw
with the giants or anything like that
and
uh i'm hoping between that the injuries
and the struggles that's where you see
the browns and obj just take off this
year and kick some butt
and think about it he did nothing to
kind of inject himself
into the nfl consciousness remember the
stuff
from from uh several years back he's in
europe and he's dancing on top of a car
and he was just like
international superstar we haven't seen
any of that from obj
in recent years and you know he has to
have been humbled
all those years he played he had one
playoff game
and they lost it was the boat trip right
he gets injured week six week five the
browns go
to the postseason beat the steelers yeah
and give the chiefs everything they can
handle without him that in and of itself
is humbling
when you spend your whole career and you
get to the playoffs one time and your
team's all in one
in the playoffs with you and your team's
one and oh and almost
two-and-oh in the playoffs without you
that in and of itself is humbling sure
a hundred percent especially for a guy
like him where you know again he just
he believes you get me the ball we win
you don't get me the ball we're in
danger of losing
and i mean in a lot of ways he was
correct about that for a long time
you know with the giants that was
correct get odell the ball
giants are going to win don't get him
the ball promise you the giants will
lose
but where he has to adjust and i think
he is
is it's different here because he's got
a real team around him you know the
giants were
not good when he was there you know the
cleveland browns
have everything like we talked about
last week we went through position by
position
and we came away going like oh it's kind
of high
high up in the hierarchy in the nfl if
you want to rank offensive line
defensive line
receivers all those type of things so uh
that that's also probably an adjustment
to him to a degree but i
i think that him and and baker will come
together this year i'm gonna be shocked
if they don't finally strike it up and
start making some special plays happen
one last point yeah it should not be
about
beckham and mayfield coming together
mayfield is in charge now
sure mayfield is the captain of the ship
so
what mayfield needs to be ready to do if
beckham
gives him any issue any complaint
any hey man i was open why didn't you
throw it to me
i'm reminded of the old story when chris
carter tried to berate warren moon in
minnesota
94 ish and moon said to him one time
if you ever do that again i will never
throw you the ball
and that was that yeah that's the end of
it that and mayfield now
i remember when they traded for beckham
i thought is cleveland big enough for
beckham
and mayfield right mayfield was the star
he was the new lebron
in 2018. now you got obj
who's really the star here mayfield's
taken over
yeah and i think it's on him it's on him
to make sure that beckham doesn't
disrupt the offense
by saying hey i was open
um you know he just mayfield just needs
to say no you weren't
sure or you need to be more open or
whatever the case may be or just shut up
we're trying to win a game here whatever
it may be it's on mayfield this year to
take that leadership
i think i think he will i think we saw
that last year i think he's
mayfield i even i think he has
handled himself the right way as well i
mean yeah there's been
mis you know misconnections are
you know times where they should have
connected on the football field they
haven't
they feel the pressure of it you know
both of them have handled things pretty
well but i i do agree with you baker's
in a different place now
to where he should feel comfortable you
know there might have been a little bit
of a ah
star struck wait i got to get this guy
the ball i hope he likes me that's
natural for a quarterback to go through
that
but now you know you should be in a
comfortable place
with him personally and in the offense
to where he doesn't think about who's
that receiver in any spot
i'm dropping back and we're gonna work
the offense and hey you're one on one
then i'll maybe play that match up and
figure it out from there but
uh that's why cleveland's exciting
because that offense became pretty damn
special at the end of the year
and now we got a guy coming back that we
know has the type of talent
to be one of the five best receivers in
football and just want to see if it all
can come together as part of this great
cleveland experiment we're talking about
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports